do you believe in submitting to a man
whose authority you trust to a certain
extent submission to me is very iffy
okay would you trust a guy's judgment
it depends
so no no no
the way you're answering is no so you're
not a submissive woman depends on the
situation because
the answer you're giving is no because
because the only the only right answer
if i said a guy whose judgment you could
trust i didn't say just anyone i said
whose judgment you can trust and you
said it depends and that that's
indicating that you can't trust them
even even back in the day if when they
needed to receive their approval uh dads
were proven guys who beat their women or
cheat on the women don't have baby
mothers so that's not that's not true
true by and large
that's why it's still a reality that's
not it
there are exceptions but it wasn't the
rules is that your view on men
my view is that your view on men all the
men throughout history were just beating
their women no i never said that no i
know but that's what you're implying
when you say anything when you say when
you say when we're talking when we're
when we're talking about a general rule
and you're saying oh but they approve
things like beating their mothers you're
you're saying that like it's common and
the words we use are important
and still like
it was acceptable to a certain extent
and it was hidden
so there was a lot of so that is your
view on man no it's not men
okay but that's your view on matt what
data do you have to support that no no
no i'm saying what what data do you have
to support that that was relevant that
happened all the time what data i never
said all the time i said there were men
out there proven guys that had this
background okay would you say it was
happening by and large
would you say it was coming i wasn't
there okay but
the way you're talking talking as if
that was a common thing no the way
you're trying to generalize and i'm just
saying that it still happened and it's
thought right but exceptions don't make
the rule
there's no such thing as rules rules are
meant to be broken what do you mean
there's no you don't think there's ever
you don't think there's any generalities
in society like some things are just but
does that mean they're supposed to be
followed no
no but then then people wouldn't get
together if if if everyone was the
exception it's not the exception then
people just wouldn't get together like
then you can't say anything
if we can't agree that there are general
things in society we can't have a
conversation about is that the base of
life just to procreate and get with
people then no but no we but we're just
saying enlarge kind of yeah yeah i mean
when when people when the girls were
saying like oh i dress for me i dress
for i dress for myself i think that
makes no sense right because if you were
the only person on the planet like the
only person you wouldn't bother putting
on makeup or anything like that
you it literally makes zero sense it's
just let a girl go out for a week yeah
or let's say a month and get no
attention
but she'll end up butt naked on the
street says someone look at me
and it doesn't have to be from guys it
can be from girls
i feel as though sometimes like our our
perception of like men and women
are um
different or that like you
people haven't met a woman that's like
um feels naturally confident in like her
natural beauty or um doesn't seek mel's
attention and i feel as though
even though it may be like the exception
like people don't necessarily come into
contact with that type of woman hence
why like the example is cap or it's like
because because there's no women
like my wife doesn't wear makeup but my
point is like yours even if it's not for
guys attention it might be because you
want to look pretty for other girls but
then why are you trying to why are you
trying to one-up yourself over other
girls why are you trying to beautify
yourself
compared to the rest of the world and
men do it as well but men just do it in
different ways right so we we are um
always trying to get a better job or
better normal success that's the
illusion we speak about so it's like a
man will happily say that i do x y and z
for a woman but then for a woman to say
in the reverse he's like no i do it for
me i do it for this idea for that in
reality no thought that you have is
original so everything we see is
regurgitated information so it's
actually impossible to not be influenced
by the people around you yeah a woman
starts to say i do it for me when it's
virtually impossible it makes zero sense
it doesn't mean that there isn't things
that women do for men there are things
just like say that then don't be like do
it for me
it also doesn't mean that a girl doesn't
dress up or put on makeup for self-love
for herself yeah exactly self-love
self-care
you're telling me the girls at carnival
walking around a thong are just doing it
for themselves
so wait why is it acceptable in brazil
for girls to be wearing the thongs and
this everyone's changing everything
culture
[Laughter]
it's like we go out of our way to find
like the craziest craziest exceptions
why
i just feel like because they exist yeah
i know but we're not saying they don't
exist but
let me finish okay i think as grown
adults we can agree that there are
exceptions to every rule but we can make
statements based on general tendencies
in society without having to stay with
every statement there's an exception i
think we can just know i i also think
it's a dream it's like it's like me
saying like i can run 100 meters in nine
seconds it's like and it's like
i can't but you're like oh but usain
bolt ran it in nine seconds so why can't
i run it in nine seconds or if i say men
men are generally taller than women and
then you point to the one guy that isn't
there's a lot of exceptions in the world
like there's seven billion people
i know do you want to talk about every
single one of them or do we should or do
maybe or would you say maybe that's not
productive to a conversation no i feel
like maybe they'll make people realize
the extent of how we don't appreciate
certain things the minimal things you
don't you don't what do you okay what do
you mean by that by the minimal things
the small like the exceptions okay such
things as the exception okay what do you
mean by appreciating the exceptions like
because like this just sounds like
nothing like we don't bring no awareness
we don't talk about it enough so like
what what exceptions what do we not talk
about just like now we're talking about
women dressing up so we need to we need
there's women that do there's women that
do uh-huh and we need to bring up brazil
why because it happens it's acceptable
in that in that place
why is it not and why is it not
acceptable honestly
it's sort of acceptable everywhere if
you go to the beaches now not just that
brazilian women
are very very submissive women so like
when it comes to how they treat their
man you can't even come close to how the
western women treat their men so that's
not even a comparison so you can let
them dress and shake bambam because when
they come home they show ultimate
respect whereas a lot of western girls
are coming home and trying to beef their
man
it's a shitty dog
i find it weird how you guys also
straight away you all said like that's
controlling right and and it is just
like a respect thing like it's not even
like i'm just asking you like why if you
truly love this person and this person
doesn't like that you dress that way
then you should at least for our respect
for the person that you love that is the
lovely for your life at least
willing to do that you know like like
and same the other way around if my wife
told me to do something
because i love and care for her i would
do do that as well like if it really
annoyed her would you guys be cool with
your your man going to the strip club
with his boys yeah yeah yeah i don't
mind yeah i'll go with him no no i'm
saying
i think it's because strip club is like
like most guys don't do anything at a
strip club so i think you have to push
it like
a little further off or something yeah
yeah
hey hey my guys don't give these girls
excuses
they're copping out with their answers
we're not going to do that the strip
club is a club
strip club you just can't get a private
dance that's it it's just me my kiss
muted he's not yeah
no no okay go ahead guys so you trust me
here you girls will say you don't you
you don't care but you'll be blowing up
his phone you'll be calling all your
girls you're planning on revenge and
doing all kind of madness so let's keep
our back club
forward what do you think
if if a guy comes late yo you're already
assuming that he's cheated on you no no
no
that's my joy
yeah that is the majority of females
that are insecure then because a lot of
um relationships are not built on trust
on our respect
don't you think it's disrespectful to
wear something revealing when you have a
boyfriend uh yeah and no and the reason
why i say yeah can i get yes or no
no no no yes yes or no okay i i i bow
out of my mind
did you say do you think he's respectful
yeah do you think it's respectful when
you have when you have a man to be
wearing something very revealing that he
wouldn't approve of well i don't know i
don't know about his approval or not i
would say that if it was my husband then
i would consider it but if if you're my
boyfriend then i'll decide that i want
to wait hold on you just say consider
yeah that means that but the thing is
i'm not going to go out like with my ass
hanging out but um if you're saying that
i just i'm not going to do nothing too
mad so you're saying that if it was your
boyfriend that you wouldn't so he should
wife you to get comp someone feel like
75 percentage of submissiveness so
somehow gets
more showing him what he doesn't want
and then you expect to get better
outcomes by showing him i'm not going to
listen to you now but put a ring on it
see this is this is we're doing it again
we're doing it again where we say we say
something about women and then we push
it on the mat take it down to billy ball
i can't take counseling one thing trying
to get in this conversation yeah is
you're you're always thinking from your
specific lens yeah the reason a man is
telling you not to behave and dress that
way is because he knows what other men
you behave like him are gonna do yeah
but then let's say for example because
i've been in a situation where i've been
with a girl she's dressed mad and then
we've got into an altercation because
another boy has grabbed her cheek that
could have been avoidable has she
dressed differently but now i have to
punch up her next man because of
stupidness you did when i could have
just told you babes that's a bit too
much but then you should have now you're
telling me in potential danger or asthma
danger as a result of you wow
i won't lie
on the woman i won't lie
who else is
because if he says don't wear that then
you wear it and there's a problem
because of it you wouldn't say that's on
you when he when he told him no that's
that's on the man that wasn't raised
right yeah
that parent
but it's like it's like there's a
there's a
there's a difference between going into
a situ it's like okay if a dude get gets
mugged at night because he's walking
alone with a big chain around his neck
do you really feel bad for him
yeah
see i always feel like pearl you have to
go to extreme with them so you have to
say he's waving it around you know and
then you're like no you don't feel me
when i'm on a dark bird i have to put my
jewels in my pocket
do you think it's smart to just leave
them out
no okay okay i have expensive camera
equipment okay is it smart for me to go
down to the bad part of london grab my
my nicest camera here and just wave it
around for people and people to take
they probably wouldn't know the value
i'm tired
okay okay can you answer the question
would that be smart would that be smart
well
probably not no
okay so could you could you see from the
men's point of view it's probably not
smart to walk around half naked when you
have a man but does that give a man the
right to touch you no it doesn't give
them the right to touch you but it's
about taking yourself out of bad
situations if you can and like women
walk around the world like like we're so
spoiled we're so spoiled as women
because we're so used to being protected
like men protect us every day in the
world they built the infrastructure for
us
how okay
when someone is attacking you who do you
call
your man
well or the police but even if you call
the police you want a man not a female
yeah
no no you're right you're right though
if you've got like five muggers on you
and two females come up you'll be like
what the f like what happened
right
men protect us every day because when
you are mugged who would you call if
someone breaks into your apartment
or my uncles yeah yeah yeah the men yeah
that's what i'm saying men tamed the
world for it used to be wars all the
time if we go into war who's going
the men
men built the world they protect us and
now we're spoiled
to the point we want to go out of our
way to put ourselves in dangerous
situations and and you have to be like
and then we feel entitled to security
sorry sorry no i was gonna say if you
want a good guy as well then you need to
be good as well like if a girl if you
generally want a guy that cares for you
and then you say no i'm gonna dress in
this way
like you're just not gonna get those
guys that you're looking for then i feel
like that goes back to what pearl was
saying about like um
being submit
submissive to a guy that you genuinely
like respect
i feel like that comes into play a lot
maybe
being submissive to a guy that you
generally respect could you talk more
about that so so say for example like if
if you um respect like your partner or
you value what he has to um say or like
say for example we say that men are
leaders and they're they are meant to
lead us to green a posture for example
like a woman would kind of look to her
partner for direction in some sort of
capacity so if me um saying that i value
my partner's decisions and his
decision-making and i and i trust that
his decision-making will be in like will
be fitting for us both then
i would consider like
not necessarily changing myself but like
some of the decisions that i would make
because it may have a negative impact on
us